so as long as we're talking about the uk
and the british people who are an older
people than us are wise people people
with a certain degree of decorum and
things of that nature let's talk about
jk rowling
who of course was the author of harry
potter who was a beloved uh character in
a beloved book michael you love those
that harry potter there and uh
you know
thank you for not yawning when i said
that um
harry potter was love jk rowling was
loved but of course now because she
defends women against having their
genitals chopped off she's a bad chick
here's some info from the daily wire
author jk rowling threw her support
behind macy gray after the singer faced
backlash for what some called
transphobic comments when she said
changing your parts doesn't make you a
woman gray was labeled a turf a
derogatory acronym used by some leftists
that stands for transgender exclusionary
radical feminists after saying on piers
morgan's piers morgan's uncensored show
that just because you go change your
parts doesn't make you a woman sorry
today feels like a good day to ensure
i've bought macy gray's entire back
catalog rowling tweeted her 13 million
followers tuesday rowling the famed
harry potter author has also been the
target of trans rights activists because
of her defense of biological women's
rights and protections so to be clear
about jk rowling what got her in this
mess i mean again this was this was a
beloved woman who wrote you know the
star wars of
our time right you first had you had
lord of the rings then you had star wars
then you had harry potter like this is
the thing that so many kids who are
becoming adults right now uh this is the
stuff that their dreams were made of
right and it was great it was actually
even though harry potter like i'm a
little old for it but like the stories
and the meaning of the stories and the
consistency and and actually what the
stories were telling you were were
pretty deep powerful things uh she was
loved by everybody then she dare say hey
uh you know girls or girls and boys or
boys now she's a bad guy and then of
course macy gray who said you know just
because you change your genitals you're
not really changing your sex now she's a
bad chick although she apologized we
showed you that video last week the like
most pathetic apology i've ever seen but
it shows the insanity of the left
they're going after anyone who basically
states things that we all know to be
true uh here's a tweet from the blaze
what's going on over at u-pen
u-pen nominates transgender swimmer leah
thomas as 2022 woman of the year
now as i say on this topic i don't mean
to be a dick about it but uh she is a
dude uh leah thomas has a penis
we did some research on that
now i'm gonna rip the mic off and walk
out leah thomas that's a penis that's it
i'm out of here um it's complete
nonsense you could i suppose and
remember she she ranked something like
467th when she was a male
now she's a female with a penis and she
ranks the number one she's the number
one
it doesn't make any sense and also
wouldn't the penis bog you down at that
point like if you're going to swim as a
chick wouldn't you get rid of the penis
just for
the ability to get through water faster
yeah
it's a oh it's a propeller that's funny
that's funny man donuts work with you